and welcome back to Hannity we are
following major major breaking news
tonight the Washington Post first
reporting tonight Fox News confirming
the Clinton and the DNC they after lying
for a year helped finance the research
for that fake news anti-trump dossier
and also breaking minutes ago Hillary
Clinton's former spokesman Brian Fallon
they're like racing Perez is the first I
regret I didn't know about Christopher
Steele's hiring pre-election if I had I
would have volunteered to go to Europe
and try to help him up really here with
reaction is the author of defeating
jihad he make America great again
coalition chief strategist former deputy
assistant to the president Sebastian
cork pops news legal analyst Greg
Jarrett what I always loved about you is
you come with a with research on
everything you start where you want your
rhenium won the dossier the confidential
informant cannot be gagged the US
Supreme Court in a but he's been gagged
he has a non-disclosure but it does not
prevent him from speaking to Congress
the US Supreme Court said so McGrane
versus Daugherty is the case you cannot
gag a witness when Congress wants to
toss it I love great Jared for all of
you at home he always knows his stuff
all right keep going all right the
Clinton dossier what strikes me is that
Christopher Steele went to the went to
Moscow and talked to the Kremlin and
gathered false evidence wait to be paid
for it
yeah now the victim here is the
president United States now and Hillary
Clinton's campaign in the DNC was
apparently paying for this for
propaganda relies for disinformation
from the Russians during the campaign Oh
Robert Muller are you awake tonight if
there's if there's collusion it's
Hillary Russia
collusion not Trump Russia collusion you
know I've been predicting this doctor
Gorka this massive boomerang for a long
time I've known that a lot of this
evidence was out there and that it was
all coming and I've been telling my
audience it's coming it's coming now
where the flood gates are opening if you
will
like the the last scene from that great
Tom Clancy movie The Hunt for Red
October where the bad submarine
commander launches the torpedo and it
comes back and it sinks his own vessel
that's what the Russian collusion story
has done for the DNC and for Hillary
let's stop using the word collusion
because the evidence we now have is
about subversion
it's about sabotaging the political
process and it's about propaganda in the
in the Cold War the Soviet Union used
what was called active measures to
undermine our democracy this is the
Democrat Party this is the Hillary
campaign using active measures to
undermine Donald Trump and to undermine
the democratic process in America it is
a shocking story and and what really
stinks here is Muller Rosenstein Andrew
Weissman and James Comey appear to have
covered it all up the uranium one deal
racketeering scheme of the Russians and
money paid to Hillary Clinton and a
sleeper agent getting close to Clinton
they never notified Congress they have a
legal duty to notify Congress Congress
would have stopped the sale of the asset
why would you ever especially in light
of everything the media and Democrats
have been saying about hostile actor
Vladimir Approval why who in their right
mind would give Vladimir Putin 20% of
America's uranium and then all the money
that flowed back it stunk to high heaven
from day one now we just have the
evidence there are two so never sell to
the Russians plutonium and uranium with
which you make nuclear weapons they have
1,200 strategic nuclear weapons aimed at
us right this minute and we're supplying
them the the nuclear material they I
will signed off on it back to them short
Gorka that's the big part of this story
so the cover-up afterwards the
destruction of evidence the gag order
that's bad in and of itself but the fact
is these people who are supposed to be
investigating this administration that
has done nothing wrong they will come
let's sit Hillary Clinton approved this
deal we they are making a big deal about
$100,000 worth of Facebook ads by Russia
half of which occurred after the
election this isn't $100,000 worth of
ads this is stuff to make nuclear
weapons being given to Vladimir Putin
can we just ingest the enormity of what
we're talking about now this this is a
massive scandal I have said and I stand
by this tonight they sold out America's
national security yes and absolutely and
there's so much more to come let's talk
about potential crimes Jeff Sessions who
recused himself you may recall in his
confirmation hearing from anything
related to Hillary Clinton he said it
not once not twice three times can still
appoint a special counsel to investigate
Hillary Clinton over uranium one her
interference on behalf of UBS
with the IRS and and received an
enormous amount of money to Bill Clinton
and their foundation and arms sales all
of that can be the subject of a special
counsel investigation while you're at it
let's throw in the email case because to
me as a lawyer it is a clear case of the
violation mishandle of the FLN Asha
destroying evidence felony obstruction
of justice deleting breaking up you know
hundred and ten counts based on 110
classified documents I want to go back
dr. Gorka you know Bill Clinton's trip
he wanted to ask his own wife State
Department to approve meeting meetings
with Russian nuclear officials okay
that's insane gets double his speaking
fee he is being paid by a bank that has
a renaissance that has a financial
interest in uranium one then he does
meet with Vladimir Putin and his wife
signs off on the deal and then the 145
million dollars came back now what other
evidence do you need to know that they
were not putting the security of this
country as their first priority
you don't need it it look a hundred and
eight emails of TSS CI
highest-level s AP classification on a
private homebrew server you know we we
we expect this from the Clintons they're
the most corrupt political clan in
modern American history but the issue is
how the establishment dealt with it
under the Obama administration how
somebody who was a suspect in that
investigation was allowed to be the
counsel to Hillary Clinton how the
blackberries were destroyed and how the
laptop said the FBI had were also
destroyed by the federal government
that's a banana republic we have a
mother has to be fired and right now a
tree sessions has to have a national
security special sense accuser attorney
general needs to wake up now this is not
a game anymore our security holder
Clinton Muller Rosenstein they all knew
in 2009 though they oppose the deal Greg
and and Holder actually sat on the
Cepheus committee if you couldn't
believe one of the ones that signed off
one of the nine it was a unanimous
decision Hillary Clinton it presides
over it all right guys we'll have you
guys back tomorrow to